what's been the hardest part of
filmmaking for you to learn
the hardest part has been for me to
learn to
to give up some of my moment-to-moment
control
and to realize that in doing that i
actually gained artistic control
i came to filmmaking i think from the
visual side and i
thought that when i started filmmaking
editing would be my favorite part of the
process where it's just me and i can
make every decision
and for a while it was and now my
favorite part is being on set
with an amazing cinematographer with
amazing actors
and being open to what that process
yields
and it's been a hard journey because
it felt like i was giving up directorial
vision at first because frankly
i think i had a misunderstanding of what
like directorial vision is i think i
thought it was
oh i'm going to micromanage every single
detail and what i've really come to
realize is that if i know
very clearly what i want what i want the
audience to feel what the point of the
movie is
if i know that and i can communicate it
then i can actually delegate a
surprising amount of work
and i will literally get that thing i
wanted because
people who know the point and know the
goal but then have space to sort of do
their own work
they produce excellent work and if you
communicate well it is work
entirely in sync with what you wanted
and then there's a flip side of someone
who's just too loose with everything
and i've seen a lot of really brilliant
creative people like that
but they never ran themselves in and
they never finish things
so how is it for you to to know that you
have the opposite problem
and just see you know are you sort of in
awe sometimes of some of these messy
creative folks
or does i mean do you sort of see the
pulp you know how they say every polar
opposite is actually there's like a lot
of similarities here
i mean i i love sort of seeing other
filmmakers process
for making stuff and then one of the
ironies of being a director
is you spend very little time getting to
see other people direct
you know i'm so envious of actors
sometimes who get to go from product to
project and just see all these different
approaches
yeah i feel like i've learned from so
many different kinds of directors from
the ones that are just
completely no plan no stuff i've learned
cautionary tales but honestly
in there a little bit of like there's
something that comes out of that freedom
and for sure even from the over
prescribed the and storyboard everything
i've learned something too
uh all of it to me seems like there are
lessons good and bad in there
and i think i'm always sort of you know
adjusting as i go
do you see your students being planners
or are they more like
hey man let's just get a camera and
shoot we'll figure the story out when
we're there
in general i think that uh the students
that i interact with
um through no fault of their own i think
underestimate
the level of planning required to use
even our seemingly accessible digital
cameras
you know we they're growing up in an era
where they can take their phone out and
press record and get video
seamlessly without any real thought
right i don't mean like intention but
just like it's just easy to do
and so i think they go through a
learning curve that's perfectly
understandable
of realizing that even with a dslr which
is a relatively easy to operate
piece of machinery there are a lot of
things you have to pay attention to to
get to come out right
and you know just literally like you
know with the f-stop and the expo and
the you know f-stop and exposure and
the iso and the resolution and uh
that making them go through those steps
so that the images are what they want
uh is one of the big things that i sort
of focus on
do you think having access to too much
information hurts people because you
know just think about gen xers
we i craved all that and there wasn't
really a place except for going like
to the library and looking on microfiche
for something but i wonder if it almost
hurts
people nowadays because there's just an
over abundance of it
yeah it's an interesting question to ask
like how does
just the amount of information and
uh and perspectives and advice and
technology that we that are flowing into
how does that affect the creative
process
uh because in some ways i think of the
creative process as being a very
solitary quiet thing for me that i'm at
my most creative
when i built a bubble even if it's for a
few minutes to just think in isolation
that being said i do think all that
stuff is fuel for
the process and yeah i'm kind of excited
you know
one of the things when i first fell in
love with instagram it was just the
ability to see
photos of people's lives all over the
world and undoubtedly that influenced me
as an artist
you know and and and so as much as like
there are times which i feel like oh my
gosh like the news and social media
and you know everything else overwhelms
and is like
a sort of a certain amount of like
background noise that is distracting
i also have to believe that it is um and
i do believe
that is also enriching my life
experience and i think anything that
enriches my life experience uh
sort of has a result creatively
so so with with let's say gen y or gen z
just having access to so much
information
being able to just ask a question and
get so many different answers back that
you feel that's
that's helpful or or does it almost harm
the creative process because now there's
too much agenda
there's two there's too many voices you
know answering
i i realize this is a really big
question but
i'm actually really excited to see what
kind of filmmakers
like the the next generation what
they're gonna do
because of yeah how they're growing up
as they're growing up first of all
you know the thing they watch more than
anything is long-form serialized content
how is that going to impact the kind of
stories they choose to tell
i fell in movies through movies you know
like my favorite things when i was
growing up were
90 minutes to two hours uh invariably
when i asked them
many of them their favorite thing is a
television show or a streaming show
or if it is movies it'll be something
like the marvel cinematic universe which
is also a form of serialized
storytelling so i'm super excited to see
how does that impact them i am super
excited to also see
what do they choose they choose to make
movies and other kinds of you know audio
visual content
what do they do given that they grew up
with so many other things to do in their
lives you know like social media and
video games and interactive like
how will that influence the few of them
who choose to do
what we might think of as filmmaking in
the future i'm just really excited about
it i just love the idea of contemplating
how each generation of artists is
undoubtedly shaped by the time they grew
up in right
and yeah i don't have a lot of pessimism
or a lot of complaints like i'm just
more just excited to see what happens
is it interesting because it's halloween
time as we shoot this interview and
going to all these different um
halloween stores just how many you know
stranger things all these
costumes yeah and and and cool like
halloween gadgets are inspired by some
of these shows
and i guess that same thing was around i
know e.t
there was a lot of you know i had one
little burger king elliot doll and
different things
um but but it just seems like now it's
it's even more
like it's there's a thirst for it yeah
and i think that you know the
the like a lot of sort of people growing
up today
like they are growing up in the in the
era of
our media is not just on screen right it
is expanding out into you know there's a
star wars
part of disneyland and there are
halloween costumes for stranger things
and there are novelizations and podcasts
and you know branded content uh and
i think that you could obviously look at
that in a cynical way or a commercial
way but i think what's exciting about it
is
it's a generation of artists who are
growing up with the stories they love
they can engage with in so many
different ways you know
for me i was just starved for content
like just waiting for like the next star
trek movie to come out you know like
and the fact that they have this ongoing
relationship with the things they love
i'm i wish i knew it was like to grow up
like that i'm sure there will create
differences
uh but it doesn't seem like a pro or con
it just seems like just a really
interesting difference and i'm curious
to see what happens because of it
you